today's show is sponsored by Roger
Daltrey's discount poultry it's not fit
for human consumption
this is difficulties with blank citation
needed I have an almost randomly
selected article from everybody's
favorite reliable source of knowledge
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact they get right gets a point
and a ding and surprise for particularly
good answers which is yeah thing is when
you whack that behind your three
chickens just shot well if it's discount
poultry there's only so many things you
will do with it irate pissed off program
members stay away from my chicken does
actually have a salmon farm low doesn't
hey that's what he retired losing weight
really retired to farm salmon oh yeah
yeah fish might be trout you see so are
we arguing about the kind of fish that
the member of the Anna's career season
farming somewhat somewhere down the line
Roger Daltry is just a fish farm Andy
what do you think like that you don't
like fish you give them player things
they like a castle or something do you
think do you think they've got a
rolls-royce in a Keith Moon gang
everyone knows okay I'm just gonna help
their brilliant if use a proper sort of
rock star style fish families say you
know just some square lake in a field
proper glass sided house or some some
management oh yes sealed at the windows
people walking past we just trout buying
it up a gigantic people tank I changed
the air all the time in bacon bits I've
given them a castle to live in and a
giant skull that's what I want to be a
people thing army you are Matt you you
already oh we need some fish outside
looking in quick consult that out it's
good I can do some compositing work on
this
excellent excellent
knows one fish to walk past bowtie
bowler hat kid in the pram you want a
fish to walk past there's no water out
there is there have to love
it'll just slide well Roger Daltry upon
the PD our topic today is the big
lobster actually sounds like a New
Orleans gangland so I was going for a
restaurant maybe the two of the same
your is gangland themed restaurant no
now themed is a front the gigantic
man-sized lobster that lives within now
you're looking a bit bigger than man
size here bigger than a lobster bigger
than a map yeah I Lobster the size of a
bear we'd have known about this it would
have walked over Tokyo by now it did
they just cleaned up after actual film
version of the bloke dressed as the
giant lobster main gentlemen may I
congratulate us on the first visual gags
a vision okay so it may not be an actual
alive Lobster it's in really is this one
of these American things where some
states got an enormous glass fiber one
to celebrate the fact that was once one
there oh oh you're right it's not us
it's not America is it in the tea roll
of Austria
just on the side of a mountain why why
have you got this lobster we stole it
from Australia
that's the worst accent ever that's not
from anywhere it teaches them the folly
of their ways prints from it from I say
this lobster is a lesson I listen to the
whole world from its claws will come
fondue yes yes yes yes great I just like
the idea of a lobster sort of aliens
over this note saying mr. Jones you are
late for your 2:30 appointment thank you
Miss Smith sorry we got an alien cuckoo
clock bearing so steampunk Siri is a
butler I'm sorry I couldn't send that
telegram just now I'll try again later
completely forget about it so Siri say
what do you what do you fetch me some
tea I don't understand what you mean
would you like me to call Tim no no
French fetch recent heat to activate him
you press his crotch yes sir very good
keeps going off in your pocket you get
different voices for it you swap out the
bottles he's got a generic man imaginary
woman yeah you know you go outside the
city he just stops working
tell me about it yeah ah the big I love
the big lobster a big lobster um don't
want I guess it what its nickname
big red it's got a name Rudy
lobby lobby mclubbe la Lobby is a lot
closer than Rudy we're looking for a
name starts with L are we talking about
Mary the lobster spot on well done so I
was gonna say if it's Australia I'm
gonna go for Wabo Castle mine Forex
brings you the fast bowling giant
Lobster Queens Lane you for it site
searching South Australia's that's
pretty really you just kind of just open
gain hot strata go from blue to red haha
so you say you've been going copter and
hotter than I thought we were gonna
drink a so we're looking an 18 meter
high huh ton Lobster here is it standing
on it so Brandon was surprisingly close
with this first guy yeah yeah I mean
that's what a hell of a lobster I'm
actually giving you a point for Samuel
it was meant to rear up over the
structure a horse style what a lobster
yes what stopped it from being built the
terrifying in the towns book or is it
near an airport or something stupid like
that so err pausing it clipped on its
big claws or something like that
planning permission yes garage garage
extension giant Lobster now we like what
you've done with the giant Lobster we're
not saying that's a bad idea what we
don't like is having it rearing up over
the whole Township I think you're gonna
see a lot of terrified folk there we've
all seen Godzilla we're all worried
about whatever it goes wrong we're 9 as
a sunshiny country what if somebody
visits their sterling the shadow of the
lobster that's it the tourism industry
it's over we're gonna have to lie your
lobster down night let's set our just
lots of rise with the council the
possibility keeping titties cool this
Lobster outline for there is a local
legend about why it's quite so big do
they want to take a shot at what that is
its final tap thing absolutely
not quite that much they they apparently
have the measurements in feet and then
read them in meters oh no oh really it
just brings in a big lorry didn't know
what our bollocks they don't ring up ago
Salman wants a hundred made a lot of
slips legit there'll be no brass for the
rest of Northwest Australia's we got the
farmer glass on this what are you gonna
use it for spruce I don't know give me
chillies cool underneath it Sriram body
okay quick fire round Australia has an
enormous amount of big things right onto
the cutting room why we have a Liam
stereotypes oh yeah okay careful not
about to start Slaton cricketers well
with it you can't play cricket on behalf
of the technical difficulties team I
would like to apologize to all
Australians it is not our fault that you
are convict alright does they want to
take hate on that would made a point
though where I will see where I work I
work in the heritage industry we have
records relating to transport ease my
favourite reason for someone being
transported to Australia goes as the
sits in that cause field so just outside
the old Sheffield region oh good lord
South Yorkshire has represented by my
good colleague hello the guy was done
for the theft of a Duke good start it's
a three strikes and you're out sister
inherently funny animal yeah but you
know when you think about that the lack
of criminal detection at the time the
Duke would have to have been in a bag
quacking and the guy caught doing it put
it back next charge is also for theft of
a look and the third one is theft of a
duck in the end it turns out it's the
same man's duck three times in the end I
think he was transport adjusting just
for being a hopeless case quite right
it's not a business ship what did you do
I killed a man what did you do I started
sheep what are you do no I sold I stole
the same
for a point H do you want to get some of
the big things around Australia twice to
push wombat kangaroo yep Timothy a
platypus yes Timmy yes a little wombat
Alice Springs are no bugs new points
there is a big ol room all the rule is
actually a small I was going to say use
their attack me it was another row in
Star Trek yes the communications officer
that falls in love with Spock in the new
movie he's a massive rock that would be
a great in a red dress yeah all the big
things in Australia a Barrier Reef okay
we're looking for models of things have
been blown up like I've personally been
to the big pineapple which is a big pine
a sense of entitlement
[Laughter]
Marlon yeah yeah yeah yeah Legos version
of something no Sydney operas or even
bigger version someone Sydney Harbour
Bridge is a bigger version of them where
mouth bridge in Sunderland yes I don't
big was some big fiberglass things in
Australia blast things much crab yes big
mud crab in Carmel I forgot a gigantic
pie awesome then I'll pie in and like
the P liquor is quite quite popular to
Sydney's the only thing I imagine it a
potty company would build yeah the big
pie is a known good above a 10 meter
pole next to the car park of a
drive-through bike shop we've got it
wrong
Yorkshire Australia Australia we take it
all back you've got a lot to teach we
want your knowledge of gigantic drive
through Asia in fact
I've had a drive through the hot beef
sandwich
that's the worst drove through that's
beef sandwich it used to be like I don't
know a popular chain of takeaway
restaurant has taken off by a local cafe
company and they just start flogging hot
beef sandwiches out of the window you
try eating a hot beef sandwich in a car
no luckily hot gravy down both your arms
before a meeting Louisiana has
drive-through daiquiri stalls what
because it's legal to have the alcohol
in your car it's not legal to drink it's
an open container so they give you the
like two pints of daiquiri and a straw
which they haven't pushed through there
and then they sell a tape over that the
straw hole is impossible I don't believe
this
yeah I was driving in America a couple
of weeks ago and filled up at the petrol
station and the entire you know there
are two queues yeah and the Rope the
dividing line between the queues not a
rope barrier crates and crates and
crates of beer
Australia has drive-through liquor
stores as well like it's based just a
big shed filled on the interior with
beer on all the walls well I think you
drive in you ask what you want the logs
in the back of your car you pay that you
drive off this is where we're not
allowed nice thing just now we just
abused that in the way that they
obviously somehow managed not to
well we already abused the non-drive
yeah I know that in Australia there was
some race like car racing thing and they
had to restrict it to just one slab as
their car lit of yes yes it's the 24
hours what's the track called it's the
suit yes the supercar 24 hour Bathurst
perfect right there's 24 hours so you're
allowed 24 hours 24 beers yeah it was
the wrong but there was an outcry
because they restricted it to wouldn't
nuts 24 beers per person yeah one on our
purpose but they said there was an
outcry at just 24 no but I've seen no
offense I got about wouldn't in per our
hours 24 hours 24 idling for more
oh yeah while driving
possibly he wants more tires so talk
about gigantic things in Australia yes
great ball creek or bat or stumps yeah
I'm gonna take maybe the big wickets in
Westbury located at the front of the
local I don't want you to give me the
big somewhere out there through taxes
it's going to be a gigantic Fred Truman
bowling at La Silla stylee
good lord that'd be brilliant so we'd
have to invade and bring him back giant
is that is a man who does not follow
cricket big things Australian kangaroo I
said that did you yeah right near the
start point you ignore the piston has an
STD koala thank you two points because
there is the big koala and the giant oh
the difference in sellings being ah not
much yeah
kookaburra oh yeah good one yep yeah cuz
they're pretty big anyway four and a
half PJ four and a half meters thing but
yes there are actually hummingbirds
really not the Kingfisher sorry I meant
hummingbirds sighs kookaburra I like the
idea of a kookaburra just sounds like a
Huey cancer
[Laughter]
kookaburra model again gigantic
fibreglass light-up eyes over a Township
squawking on meow oh yeah oh yeah I've
got a real horrible grating yet where's
the sound they use for the monkey in
every jungle movie film before 1980 yeah
mmm in a monkey not even on shooting
shark they just try and get it to feel
the roll you know you lift their head
butt like a between eggs I went to
bloody Rada I don't know why I do all
the monkey with it on that note
congratulations to Chris stealing it at
the last moment with an enormous number
of big things you know it so
congratulations you win a DVD of the
film where the singer of Purple Rain
trades places with a peasant who looks
just like him the artist formerly known
as Prince and the pauper until next time
that's Ben Mac right that's been Gary
drama that's been Christie all I've been
Tom Scott we'll see you next time
[Laughter]
you made it through to the end well done
if you like this then tell a friend
leave a comment or send as a carrier
pigeon plus we've got all new episodes
of our reverse trivia podcast at Tech
death Co you K